Тут, коли мені було 6 років, я вперше заробила свої гроші — я тут працювала.
Отже, сюди завозили зерно із колгоспу, всюди-всюди було зерно.
Комбайн на 2-3 поверх це піднімав, воно сушилося. Тут донедавна пахло ше зерном.
Тут постійно павутиння, павуки, і різні комахи — ми їх виносимо в комашинний готель.
В нас тут усе, як кажуть, для природи.
Близько 2-3 років ми боролися з тим стереотипом, що тут можна шось запропонувати.
Ніхто цього не розумів. Казали: "Як можна купити собі щось з щурами, і хотіти туди приводити туристів?"
Зробити щось у колишньому зерносховищі — це така трохи божевільна ідея, хоча я запрошую місцевих, щоб побачили.
В нас тут у фермерських будинках теж роблять корчми на вихідні, і ми тут пропонуємо закарпатські гуляння.
У нас тут до 50-ти людей. Ми робимо лемківські весілля.
Приїжджають туристичні групи, і ми беремо з них пару. Ми одружуємо туристів тут, в народних костюмах,
за всіма традиціями. Місцева фолькльорна група тут співає, місцеві сусіди-родичі готують їсти,
з місцевих продуктів. Місцеві дівчата допомагають на стіл виносити, прибирати, тощо.
Я купую місцеві продукти тут, щоб заспокоїлись, що це добре, коли туристи приїжджають.
Ми дуже раді в першу чергу велотуристам, бекпекерам. Вони можуть бути грязні.
У нас є літній душ. Ми пропонуємо там, в бабусі і гарячий душ. Тут можна посушитись.
Тут можна полагодитись. Ми тут говоримо 3-4 мовами. Хочемо, щоб велотуристи тут почували себе комфортно.
Те, що ви побачите нагорі німецькою мовою називається — Matratzen Lagerbier.
Матраци ми зробили так свідомо, тому що їх можна переставляти, забирати, додавати.
До 16-ти спальних місць — це велосадиба.
Це дуже такий дешевий вид відпочинку, на сайті booking — 60 грн з особи коштує.
Це велосепедисти, які зазвичай з палатками їздять, але якщо мокро,
або не хочуть, то можуть заїхати до нас.